[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: How does Google
design a data center that
can support millions
of connected end points
and requests simultaneously?
At Google, it took 18 years of
work downloading an entire web
and index.
Back in the early days,
we ran on a limited number
of high-end traditional
enterprise servers and storage
in a shared facility,
leading to what's
now one of the world's
largest computing systems
made up of multi-acre
sized data centers.
A data center consists of
compute, storage, networking,
and power and cooling
infrastructure
in order to handle demand.
Think of all the parts
like building blocks
that talk to each other.
Red blocks are server halls
with compute and networking.
Green are power supply.
And blue are cooling
infrastructure.
Let's start with red blocks--
server rooms.
Chips comprise
processing and memory
in a server, which also
includes hard drives or storage.
These servers are
consolidated into racks
and positioned into rows.
Thanks to Moore's Law, we
can process more information
than ever before in a
smaller computing unit.
Today, that means a single
data center building
with thousands of
server racks holding
thousands of gigabytes of data.
All of this is possible
through our green blocks--
power supply.
An electric system
feeds into the building
and provides a steady stream of
electrons flowing to servers.
And just in case our
electric system goes out,
we employ a backup energy source
to provide redundant power
supplies to servers.
A mechanical system also
feeds into the building
to help remove heat from
hard working servers.
These high-density servers
generate a lot of heat.
But by continuously raising
the operating temperature
in our data centers as
computing technology allows,
we use less energy.
And that leads us to
our next crucial piece--
our blue blocks-- cooling.
Hot/cold aisle is a
server aisle layout
that increases the
effectiveness of the cooling
system by managing airflow.
Server racks are
lined up with cold air
facing one way and hot
exhaust facing the other.
We distribute chilled water
through an array of pipes
over to fan coil units
that service the racks
and help disperse heat.
As the water is
warmed by the servers,
it's moved through
an array of pipes,
then to a cooling tower
for evaporative cooling.
Using blocks as a framework,
designing a data center
becomes easier.
The real challenge-- massive
scale and the core principles
behind running a data center.
More on that next on
Discovering Data Centers.
If you want to learn more, check
out google.com/datacenters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]